this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everybody it's good to be back so
first I want to give a little spiel
about the Pritchard career fellowship
Awards so it was started in 1956 by
Frederic career and it's available to
plan students and landscape architecture
students at Cornell to leave you know to
study plants like a horticultural topic
of their choosing outside of the United
States in Canada and so this has been
going on for over a papist entry it's
funded by an endowment so it's not just
for horticultural students it has to
follow horticultural topics so right now
we have a Plant Pathology and a plant
breeding student that are also away on
country or fellowships right now
Meaghan Hall isn't in Tasmania she works
on I cotton grape sour rotten with Wayne
Wilcox and James Keach works on
inpatient breeding and he's in Thailand
right now and he was working on the
propagation of orchids and so there's a
real big there's a rich history and a
plethora of topics that people have
studied on this award and a big part of
it is to you know I'm thinking I'd just
like to get an experience not
necessarily just study one thing in
particular for the purpose of doing
research to produce a product but to
before I put that recipient to get to
experience how things are done like how
plants are grown in a different part of
the world so like Don mentioned I had
worked in in California and in Chile
which are more Mediterranean climates
and then it was a big shot coming to you
know to upstate New York to see how
things are grown here and you know I've
certainly learned I get learned a ton
and like during my master's and but I
wanted to take a look at Spanish major
cultural practices for a number of
reasons so I'm familiar so it has a long
history of viticulture this is like a
mosaic in medida which is from the Roman
era wines been being has been made in
Spain for over 3,000 years there are
hundreds of rivals native to the area
they
have more vineyards you know more area
planted a vineyard than any other
country in the world and Spain but they
ranked number of fourth in the world and
wine grape production largely because
it's a really dry area that I've ever
sees of little precipitation and they
don't have good access to irrigation
yeah like sources to irrigate with and
in fact until 1996 it was illegal to to
irrigate vineyards and Spain they have
made that legal since and so that's
starting to pick up but with such a long
history of dry farming it is something
that really interested me you know -
especially with water becoming you know
such a hot-button issue when it comes to
vertical term in terms of farming and
like if you take a look at the
California will see you in half what and
I how things evolve down I'm also put in
Spanish so that make things easy - like
for me to get around so fortunately and
I was able to like to start to head out
like the head over in August I love to
go to Spain so as you can see Spain has
these really tall mountains going right
up right across the top of it so they
have the Pyrenees right here and then
you have the Cantabrian mountains the
Pecos the the Europa that really I sever
off the rest of the Iberian Peninsula
from like from northern Europe and this
makes I go like has a rain shadow across
the entire area you also have like so
this is like a map that shows altitude
not dryness so you can see that they
have this large central plateau the mist
at the center out and so you have like
this area that's relatively dry and
relatively high in altitude here is a
map that shows you like precipitation
throughout the country so you can see
that the majority of the country
receives somewhere between three hundred
to seven eight hundred milliliters of of
water a year and you can see that along
the top you have this big band formed by
the mountains in here it's Galicia
Winston I can a story as soon as Green
Spain I talked more about that area but
you can see where the vast majority of
you know Spain is I
there sits in this rain shadow so the
first place I want to go I went to go
visit when I went there was to visit my
friend Ignacio I met Ignacio about five
years ago when I was living in Peru
I was his English teacher immediately I
was a great English teacher I think my
better horticulturist then I am a
Spanish teacher
uh-uh English teacher sorry but he since
received a job promotion and now lives
in Madrid and so it was I have to say
like it was wonderful having him and his
family there if I ever wanted a
home-cooked meal and I was in town was
always there I could leave extra extra
things there and but the first the first
place we went was up to sign de gallo
and up here in these mountains here we
are and so it just shows you this giant
like that's what like severs the rest of
Spain from France
like that's France right here along like
a border goes right along the top to
those mountains and so that's what
really divides you know Spain from the
from the rest of Europe I also went out
there to go to the Pyrenees where there
are no vineyards right off the bat
because in August Spain really goes on
vacation I thought that it was just a
term that people said let's say
Europeans go on vacation and August but
really the country shuts down yes there
are lots of cities centres that are just
really empty and vacant then but
afterward next so I decided to go see a
couple of places that had really wanted
to see and then I could focus on being
able to visit a lot more professionals
later and so my first trip to study you
know a grapes went down into Mumbai
which is and Andalusia and southern
Spain because they're starting to
harvest you know I guess so they
couldn't go on vacation and so redonda
is most famous for its bridges this was
built in the 18th century they have
several of them that span these giant
gorges up on this major patio where
ronzo States but it is okay used to be
in the Roman era a major production of
grape vines after flocks for a hit they
really pared down but now you can see so
these are olive groves right here
vineyards and all of this is wheat
production
primarily but during the summer I feel
harvest in late spring early summer and
you'll have a lot of barren grounds from
there so it's um
really sort of like really shocking to
see I ain't no there's like vibrant lush
grape canopy is coming out of this area
that's otherwise so brown and so I went
to discuss Olivia Howe it's a winery in
a 16th century monastery and they found
these paintings behind layers of plaster
and paint it's and they just decide to
over to restore them but it's a
beautiful beautiful place and when like
I hung out with their knowledge is
descent they and showed me around their
vineyards and so they do a lot of really
interesting things as like in comparison
to other areas that I'm used to
they like to try and crop heavier and
not leaf pull like you would think in
many areas not because like to have more
protection for the grapes to just hit
them you can see that this is what the
campus look like so they have that
really cuts down on their labor costs
where they don't like what they have to
do very little they don't really have to
do much in terms of hedging etc because
the vine just can't grow that much as
far as other interesting practices
they'll plant vines and they'll after
the first growing season they'll cut
them down to just two buds on the Scion
just so they can promote all of that
nice and I get more resources towards
root growth in those first years and
yeah if something really really tasty
one but this is a growing region it
hasn't been active starting to have a
renaissance of growing grapes after it
got shut down for a while another area
that I visit which is a little bit
further to the east by the town of Napa
is like or these vineyards which are if
I'm at about a thousand meters here and
you can see the ocean after this is the
Mediterranean down here by this up these
windy roads that are yeah so as the crow
flies you're only a couple of kilometers
away from the ocean but you're up really
high and these are Muscat Olivia and
Vidya
grapes and so this has a really
interesting history because they were
originally used to make wine
historically but by the
it's a Muscat a white Muscat grape but
they were kept in the region by the
Moors when they came by because they
make great raisins but now there's a
move to take these already existing
vineyards then shift them from raising
production towards wine production and
they make a really lovely white wine
it's a dry it's a dry musk outline so it
has those egg terpene neck type type
notes those overripe honey tip flavors
but it's a dry wine it's it's really
nice if you can you can find a bottle
but after that I went to hit a switch is
by the city of of cavies which is here
and it's where sherry is produced and
this is one of my favorite places that I
got to visit in Spain I didn't really
think that I didn't know that much about
sherry it's has this reputation maybe
like past generations really I'd like to
drink sherry as an after after dinner
drink and a big reason why it's a as big
as it is is that it sits right by the
port city of Cadiz Cadiz is the oldest
city in Western Europe the Phoenicians
founded it about three thousand years
ago people have been making wine there
for three millennia and sherry is made
in three cities so heba is Santa Marta
and son Luke are and between this
triangle is where all of the grapes are
grown primarily Palomino is the name of
the grape and then aged in wineries in
these three cities and so this is what
the area looks like it's these rolling
hills close to the ocean with these
really you know calcareous soils
anything that is green here is grape
vines and they crop extraordinarily
heavy it reminded me of Concord
production around western New York where
you have these extremely high yields you
can get up to like 20-some tons per
hectare
the grapes have really little acid they
have they don't have that much sugar you
can only ferment them up to maybe ten
eleven percent alcohol and yeah they're
not the only really have any flavor
they're kind of just a body to then do
aging with
and so then you have all of these sherry
houses where they have a system where in
order to maintain uniformity of the
product of sherry bill and have them
Aging in these like where they decant
maybe 10% down from the top this will be
like the youngest wine though the
coaster year they'll put 10% down into
here which goes down into there and then
on the on the floor is the oldest and
that will head off to market then and so
there's some wine in here that's
probably close to 100 years old it's
been diluted down all that time but in
order you can maintain the consistent
product because this has traditionally
been the sherry spent something that is
shipped you know it's 80 percent of the
market it goes outside of Spain still
yeah it gets really remarkable in the
same point and also because the grapes
have so little character the terroir and
like the difference that you get between
different areas really comes more from
what city look what the climate is like
in the city where these things are aged
for 25 years or so before and yet before
they're released which is really
fascinating there's you know part of it
is they have headspace in the barrels
where it's about 15 percent alcohol in
here and then a yeast layer grows on the
top layer and some on the bottle as well
but the yeast produce that can like a
waxy film that helps separate the
protected one from oxidation and it
gives it these beasty flavors so that's
what a Fino sherry is the more nutty
sherry as those have a higher alcohol
and those are stored without this
biological layer here yeah I can so
that's just straight-up oxidized wine
essentially that's been fortified and if
that's what the flavor you're going for
it makes a great wine to shuffle over
the world because like you can't really
get any worse you know yeah so you know
I already has it's already oxidized it
has high alcohol content so as far as
something that you can put in a barrel
and send out all over the world it's a
pretty resilient no I like pretty
resilient thing to ship so like
yeah that's been really interesting to
learn about there are a number of
different things that you can do a lot
Commission's to there's the biological
aging there are there's something in
between caught in Amontillado which is
just fun to say you know and then there
are like your dry sherry sweet sherry is
where you add you know like sweet wine
from my capital mayonnaise grapes like
there's too much to get into in just
like I have like 45 minutes to go
through everything they have these
traditional zones called to Mancos which
are like traditional areas where you go
to drink sherry
this is pepe and he has his family's
been running this tobacco for about a
hundred years and he try to show me how
the public ortho is it's made like on
the on the bar counter yeah I was here's
a fun time but he also he also showed me
how like told me about a research
station a germ plasm collection close by
him that I was able to go visit which
was really fascinating so I met with dr.
Miguel Beneatha's and he is like the
head of the shrimp Osmond collection
it's one of the two chief germ plasm
collections in Spain and so it was a lot
of fun to see a lot of different
varieties that they have there the
clonal selection like the oldest
criminal selection in Spain was done in
have a hard-edged was one of the first
cities in the world to have electricity
like wine really push this like push
this video is like a like a really
wealthy the city of splendor like back
in the day and all of it was tied to
grapes and so they have a long history
of like a research going on in this area
so as they learn a lot from him running
at like walking around our research
station this isn't MIT this is my own
era which is one grape that they're
trying to bring back that's really up to
the area I'm really big berries as you
can see and they have these lines along
them they're really fascinating you can
see like there I am in
they're in a research station yeah
canard like they're different
fermentation trials now if there's a lot
of fun but then after that I shot clear
across Maine and up to Bordeaux because
why not no I there are like I have to
like like I don't know if any of you
know my Adele of ia she was a master
student in food science working in in
anology her family owns the de la vie a
winery in in Napa and she is currently a
student at the University of Bordeaux
and so when I knew that she was there
she invited me to crash on a couch so I
couldn't refuse that invitation also
many of you probably know miss Amanda
Sims a former student of Allen Lac so
she came over to and like like so we
overlapped and could go visit Bordeaux
together which was a lot of fun to have
a double companion that spoke a
smattering of French I don't speak any
French it's just none but here's a
general map of you Nicole Bordeaux it's
the largest appellation in France no
it's really the diversity there is
really amazing so like you have the
medoc around here which is more flat and
gravelly you have sought turns being
made around around ROVs then you have
the whole Sun Milian area I don't want
to get into too much detail on this but
it was really amazing to see places that
produced five dollar bottles of wine
versus 500 euro bottles of wine which
was something else you can also see that
they have really really tight spacing
yeah and so this plays out with how they
spray it like so here they're sprayers
really really narrow they can spray four
rows at one time and even though they
have like such tight planning maybe a
meter a meter and a half between rows
and maybe a meter between plants they're
able to have a really high density of
canopy in this you know in this system
which works out really well it also
makes the vines compete with one another
because they're in more wet climate so
that works out to their right to their
favorite you can see like how these
things look like when they sneak through
through these vineyards that a lot of
them have these spider looking tractors
that go over
rose which is pretty cool to see I also
got to visit
Cheval Blanc Klaus Van Leeuwen who came
last year I who is a professor at the
University of Bordeaux also does some
consulting work with like with Cheval
Blanc which is one of like the
highest-end Bordeaux's in the world
which is a lot of fun to see how they do
do this these are their concrete tanks
they look funny I get in funky there's
no practical reason for that just
because they look pretty I asked there's
yeah yeah they look cool but like that's
definitely reason I also was able to see
some really cool ground cover and
management practices so this is a semi
own block and like an assault turned
vineyard the older vines they because
the production is lower they'll leave no
ground cover whereas in a newer vines
they will leave ground cover to try and
équilibre the you know the two blocks at
cheval blanc they'll have cultivation
practices where they try and move the
top ten ten centimetres of ground where
they push it under the vines and bring
it back down to try and keep roots from
growing in that top layer which prevent
them from absorbing water during summer
rains which could help promote berry
splitting or the dilution of flavors so
it was fun to pick up a little bit of
know-how what they do around there but
then after Bordeaux I went to I use
Basco aren't here and to Gleason's that
this is greenspan so this is where a lot
of white wine is is made in the country
so here are a bunch of a winemaker I
forget her name I in Yaqui I think it is
like there like the bush could i names
are like that like the past names are
really difficult to pronounce for me but
she's like she had a great conversation
tell me about how she manages her
curbing is in this area to make Chalkley
which is a really high acid wine that's
grown in in pais vasco it's really
really interesting area it's really
similar to the Finger Lakes reminds me a
lot of the finger look except for it
like the palm tree is around there but
that's just I know you're risen I guess
that they they can survive the winters
it doesn't get that cold during the
winters but they have really similar
problems with down email
and I things of that manner here you
have normal VSP chalices but mostly area
they have pergola trellises where you
have these posts and a bunch of wires on
top where it creates essentially a roof
over the vineyard it allows them to
achieve much higher yields but it also
makes mechanisation nearly impossible
they also have these really cool
tractors where you have like because
they're still low you can't enclose it
so you have to have these really low
tractors to be able to get underneath
there and then these guys were these
space suits we hooked up to respirators
no order to get through there yeah so
again it's just like funny to see like
how creative people get to deal with
these different situations
now here's Barbara she like this isn't
an Albertini Oh Vineyard and British
buys us you can see there's a lot of
granite everywhere in this area as well
you can see the pergola system here is
supported by granite posts everything is
made of stone they're even even vineyard
posts it was also really interesting to
see the different pace of how people
work here like I was saying this has to
be done I like most of the work here has
to be done by hand and this is a picking
crew they're paid by our not by weight
like a car in the United States and yeah
people are just kind of like taking or
like they're kind of taking their time
guess just going through there's a
different pace to how everything is done
but wages are still relatively low and
so as you can see at what the price
points of wines aren't you know in the
liquor store that Spain is really
competitive for especially for the
quality of what they produce there's
also a lot of people that do their their
own farming like on a small of us so you
can see you'll see just like a couple of
you know I like older women driving
around these are probably I think these
are la brusca grapes right here I like
they're harvesting harvesting to make
wine on on their own there's still a lot
of people that make their own wine make
their own cider I things like that and
have their own small plots now it's like
a big part of culture to have with your
own garden have your own small vineyard
their lot
people that have fairly sighs I feel a
large tracts of land that they take care
of and so after Galicia I went on to
Thoreau and then to Verde Verde Duetto
which are some of the more famous areas
so I couldn't think of anything more
unlike Galicia when I got to Touro which
is just this dry son big barren place
with really sandy soils these vines
they're spaced 3 meters apart thanks to
3 meters by 3 meters and there's really
there's very little work that people
have to do you have to cultivate once a
year in the spring because after that
nothing can can reestablish roots I'd
get so tried these vines are not grafted
there's no flux right in this area
flexure I can't I can't grow in finest
there the sandy and they producing like
a variety called Tina they thought oh
which is really really dark in rich it's
it's really interesting and but again
I've mostly costs or everything is hand
has to be hand done you have to hand
thin you have to hand prune you have to
hand pick you can't you can't mechanize
any of this and so as as things change
we'll see what the difference is I mean
a lot of the differences that I saw
between my newer vineyards and older
vineyards is trying to bring in the
capability to mechanize here's the big
thing so putting things on a trellis for
no other reason just to be able to
harvest it mechanically but it's really
difficult to do that when you need to
maintain spacing this this white apart
there are no like there like there's
nowhere to find water to irrigate here
even if you wanted to so that kind of
dictates how you know you know like how
are you able to grow in these areas just
to see here so this is the difference in
there so carbonic carbonic lis macerated
grapes neck to make wine are really
coming here you can see the difference
in color that this makes as opposed to a
traditional wine and so like adds a lot
of writing fruitiness there
like if you ever see that and it's
carbonic Li macerated it means that the
initial fermentation was done in an
absence of oxygen with whole areas that
fermented a little bit inside of
themselves that produced these really
distinct flavors you should try it if
you have it and then after that I went
to pretty edited wet oh I really think
that so this like a newer area you can
see a really wide spacing there and it's
right by the Rio de Guero so a lot of
these areas have irrigation really more
of a security system than anything else
but because it's a really flat valley
they're able to take it away with this I
have big spacing big vines a lot of the
areas are you can see there's everything
it's just on a really large scale here a
lot of this is because it wasn't a like
a big traditional wine producing area
and here's a view from on top of a
castle oftentimes they would have the
best views of the landscape and a lot of
this used to be sunflower in week and it
was only recently turned over in the
1980s they started to do this and so I
think that actually a lot of the better
budget wines coming out of Spain are
coming from pretty bad a duet Oh or do
has maybe the more famous area I'm a big
big proponent and fan of things coming
out of pretty better they the wet Oh
especially for like your more economic
ones
yeah again so you have a lot of like
large large volume production facilities
most of what they go around there is
Tempranillo but I tried maybe the best
throughout my life when I was there this
is a winery called
bodegas we saw I was able to meet up
with the owner Felipe yeah actually then
he invited me to a both my dock
afterwards which was a lot of fun like I
don't know how I feel about that yeah
it's really it's really I mean like I
think it's something that I'm glad I did
I don't know if I'd want to go to more
bullfights but it's it's a really
beautiful spectacle but pretty gruesome
at the same time but yeah so so pretty
better though I don't what next is maybe
by volume I don't like this second most
important wine producing area the most
important one is Rioja or the most
famous one is Rioja which is situated in
this little Valley here so you have
of just the stunning-looking Valley this
is what it looks like there I mean like
there's nothing better than just getting
a rental car and cruising around these
small little towns dotted with these
medieval walled towns it's stunning it's
my favorite place in Spain the food is
fantastic as well and logo Tonio is a
city of like the capital has about
150,000 people in it it's a must-see but
you can see that you have this small
patchwork of you know of vineyards here
I mean if they've been producing wines
here for a very long time a lot of the
parcels most of them are under a hectare
in size and like I met some family as
they've been it had like titles to these
blocks since the 1400s yeah so it's a
really interesting area in terms of how
people able to work this with this
patchwork in this history a big reason
why it became such a big famous wine
producing area is because when flocks ro
was ravaging France a lot of French
winemakers came to radio had they had
good connection with rail lines going
back up to France and so it's like
excellent wine grape producing region
and they brought a lot of French
technology of winemaking technology down
to down to Spain in terms of aging and
oak barrels different treatments like -
you know like - it really boosted the
quality of the wine so like so like that
potential from the grapes are always
there but them French influence really
helps it and I advanced the the quality
of their wines there and so it has a
much longer story the on like the virus
on the I think it is yeah these are well
these are also Tempranillo x' and like
this is later in the season closer to
harvest and Tempranillo and like your
think of it as if the Spanish grape that
is able to survive you can what you
think as this hot Mediterranean climate
it's a lot more finicky then then I
thought it was so this is relatively a
relatively cool climate in comparison to
a lot of other areas in Spain and so it
really gets zapped when you have it in
can higher heat areas also wind can
really easily damage it shoots and so
when that happens then they'll send out
a secondary shoot and then that'll have
fruit that comes out off of a secondary
which blooms later which means that it
it's too late and ripeness like behind
the primary crop which can cause big
problems when you're trying to harvest
that block because then you'll have a
bunch of unripe fruit that's mixed in
which which isn't good so you want to
have it in the in the right conditions
to grow that I think that's why you
don't really see it outside Spain that
much it does really well under these
specific conditions but it hasn't really
adapted well hasn't really been exported
that well to other areas because I think
that there are a number of factors that
it really needs - I like to produce good
wine but you can see it up here so they
have the you know like the contagion
Mountains right up right against the
north you can see that it really stops a
lot of bad weather from coming in here
if you like if you just cross over that
mountain range you're in you know you're
on a studious you're and they like in
the can't a brain area around pais vasco
right up there which is a really really
green zone like from where I was showing
you those photos earlier and so yeah
it's like this really stunning landscape
Oh rose bushes yeah people say that
that's - I guess I carry in the coal
mine for different diseases attacking
them I don't buy that I think it's
really more of traditionally I destroy
Dubai is putting in marriage so that
horses traditionally wouldn't scratch
the end posts and dislodge them because
they were covered in thorns if that's
the one I think is more feasible but you
can just see it's this really beautiful
area like with this with a small
patchwork of you know vines everywhere
which is I think would be a nightmare to
think to try and control but also you go
up the sides of these hills into it
makes it really difficult to irrigate in
this area as well so you don't see much
irrigation also because so many of these
vines are so old it just be really
difficult to install a system that would
work but you also have a lot of your
older like premium wines being produced
there this is
Otacon Pompeo they have this big
labyrinth of caves underneath their
facility which is really something to
behold and I got like some exquisite
wine it's like fantastic but like things
that are normally out of my price range
like yeah so I think that were do huh
makes a great excellent wine but I guess
far as their base level like there are
other regions in Spain but I think have
a lot more potential than or do ha does
yeah kind of like you're fine nuanced
wines they're really good I don't think
they're as good as like your yeah like
your baseline make them yeah you know I
think your grad students happy type wine
they're also in the town of briones if
you're ever in in or do hi this is the
best wine magazine I'm a wine museum
that I've ever been to it cant reminds
me of the Corning Museum of Glass where
I've you all been to the Corning Museum
of Glass yeah where they have a great
science section and then they have a
great art section and it really ties the
two together absolutely I always kind of
interested me in bit of culture and
analogy as well here's a collection of
all of their of a bunch of different
corkscrews they probably thought they
have tens of thousands of cork screws
all lined up and you know according to
their different styles but they also
have like there's a wonderful section on
how to go grapes how to make corks how
to make barrels how to make bottles I
kinda make glass bottles because I have
this great technology area and then they
have a beautiful beautiful art museum
all like this dedicated to wine actually
they have all biblical scenes like that
that feature wine or cups that are ten
thousand years old that were used to
serve wine from from Persia or like
Picasso's that feature a bottle of wine
it's really something else and plus it's
in Briones which is this beautiful old
medieval towns I really can't say enough
about Rydia Hyde's really something else
but after Rioja I started an internship
in the time of boertie which is an auto
going at the Capitol is is is that a go
support huh
it's a town of about 5,000 people there
isn't a whole lot going on there it's a
really agricultural town there's a lot
of fun to live
just to get that like authentic
off-the-beaten-path experience although
bored how recently became famous because
it is the home right next so here is
like the owner know the head of
viticulture for Bodega spore sow who I
was working for we literally got to go
around to hundreds and hundreds of these
small vineyards up in these you know I
keep like a high high areas the best
majority is is garnacha it's also spread
in with a lot of almond orchards almonds
are going bananas up there because yeah
well no because because of the drought
in California it's really boosted the
price of almonds on the market and so
there's a big move towards almond
production and in this area they're
doing really well with that but you also
have you know all of these small small
plots of grapes in this area as well and
so forth I was part of a collective
there are maybe 600 different farmers
some of them are a professional farmers
full-time like they'll they'll produce
olives or you know you know like almonds
or like a grapes and the collective has
to buy all the grapes there so there's a
big diversity and it can what get to
produce do you have wine that's made
into like five liter jugs that it sell
for five euros or there are like you
know like core notches that 100 points
from Robert Parker and cost you know
close to a hundred dollars a bottle so
there's a really big diversity which is
so much fun to see such a diversity in
vineyards when I was out there it was
you know I mean like it was so much fun
especially to work with I'll bet the
entire time a guy just like he's been
working he's from the area he's been
working there for 20 years for this
company I don't know how he knew where
all the different vineyards were
everything was just this maze of dirt
roads and somehow he would know how to
get to all these different little under
1 hectare size plots all the time a part
of it that was really interesting is
that we did really very little chemical
analysis of grapes to figure out when we
were harvest and
what kind of wine to make we are doing
everything by taste yeah so we would
just go around and eat grapes all day
which is actually really bad because
these are really really tannic and and
sugary grapes and I was thinking about
it too much like chewing on chewing on
things too long and I destroyed my mouth
within a couple of days I had like all
chapped lips and like sores my tongue it
was really bad
fortunately I was able to like to get
faster with you know with how I would do
I go on with all the tasting but being
able to do that and taste from so many
different vineyards and talk to someone
who's an expert was maybe the most
important thing that took away from ya I
from working there it's a skill that you
like it's a really unique opportunity to
I especially be able to like to taste
from hundreds of vineyards to make all
these comparisons which was a lot of fun
Borja is famous i recently whistle news
it became famous because it's the home
of the edge a home oh they board hum
which is that tiny oh wait sorry like so
yeah it's too many slides I get mixed up
in what's coming next but yeah so this
is a very large winery um so this is
like you have like machine harvested
grapes being dropped off to a
subterranean crusher that then push
things to the large tanks yeah I could
really like large facility it would go
through you know thousands and thousands
of tons of grapes really impressive but
it also do small a lot fermentations as
well a big big range but it's home of
actually almost a bort I don't know if
you've seen any of this I so that's what
Bora is most famous for is this funky
painting that this woman was going to
restore and did a horrible job on it but
now it's more famous than ever it's
bringing in tours from all over the
world to take a look at this you know
get this painting so that's what looked
like before that's what looks like now
that's the restoration job but I would
argue that it is not the weirdest or
creepiest painting in born hump there is
this great cafeteria that I think I can
became friends with the owner and eat
there like have like my lunch and dinner
there every day and this is hanging up
in his restaurant so this is a painting
it's an original from the 80s and that
is the former king of Spain Carlos so
this I got like Spain here being upheld
by a bunch of hands and then you have
like a rather spelt bare-chested King
Charles wearing a gold necklace with his
arms crossed growing out of the land as
long as well as like a naked pair with a
pregnant woman yeah look at that every
day like four or five weeks for lunch
and dinner I'd see that every day just
looking at it yeah what a yeah so
there's that that I'll never forget that
but this is what they like what I think
the area is should be more famous for
it's just these old vine like these old
old Grenache of mines a lot of them are
60 years plus and exist these gnarly old
looking vines but they produce some of
the most exquisite tasting wine that
I've ever tried
it's really something else yeah so that
was a lot of fun you could also have
these fiery red soils and I could like
just a big diversity and like and what'd
you find out there's a beautiful area as
well as you can see it does it wasn't it
wasn't a bad place to hang out for him
for a while yes we learned a lot there
and here's something to show you like so
go notch it's the most planted red
variety in like red grape variety like
from wine in the world
and so here's Tempranillo on either side
and this is garnet you can just see that
it is resilient it can take a beating it
crops heavy but it really liked it yeah
so this is lately in the season it's
always the last thing to come in just
because it you know it can really hang
on there like an under these under these
conditions you can see that Tempranillo
is starting to fall apart like that like
I could identify what variety of
vineyard was from hundreds of meters
away just because you can see like the
the condition that the canopy is in so
so Grenada is really pretty beastly
heavy duty grape that can handle
a lot of different conditions but I
think it really needs these to produce
high high quality fruit I think that a
lot of people plant it in other areas
just because it can handle adversity but
a lot of times they crop it really
really heavy it doesn't really work out
that well yeah it's like that was a lot
of fun to learn about garnacha but after
that harvest was over there wasn't
really too much more to do but apples
were still in season so I went up to a
studious to learn about side of
production and as many of you know I'm
really interested in apples in cider and
so a studious is a really really
beautiful area so it's wedged between
the picos de europa so this is what the
mountains look like in the area really
we're there you'll see lying herds of
goat and sheep like goats and sheep
walking through there with shepherds
they make a lot of cheese up there and
bordered by the sea as well it's just
like a really really stunning area but
they have a strong tradition making
cider just because grapes don't really
grow on that area so it's really
different than other varieties of cider
that you may be aware of because it is
more acidic now has to go to malolactic
fermentation
I'd like that is so acidic and it's not
carbonated but to aerate it
they port from up like remote like at
all Heights oh this isn't it in a cedar
area where they pour it from you know
like the waiters hold it above their
head and have these little splash guards
because otherwise you'd make a mess
everywhere there's someplace that I have
drains in the floor where they just hose
the place down every night the
traditional way to do it is out of a
tank I can so this is say Tsar he was
really really nice showing me around the
whole area and you can see the
traditionally they were served out of
out of tanks needed like all the mess
that he's making them at the splashing
around like so like I don't think that
Spanish cider traditionally can be
expanded just because it's it's it's
it's own thing yeah can you supposed to
just pour a little bit and then down it
in ya in a few gulps when it's still
cloudy with all of the gas and
carbonation from it but it's you know it
was a lot of fun to learn about their
their production practices I met with a
couple of professors that study this
most of the what much the orchards are
really small in size because you have
such diversity in
in topography in the area then you'll
have a lot of people that just manage
these as a as a side business it's not
their full-time job and so and because
of that they don't they don't fruit then
they don't spray anything they just grow
apples harvest them and turn them into
cider so it was really interesting to
see I know different strategies for
going is like in these minimal
investment orchards in this area you can
just say I'm then they just drop them
off you'll have all these different
varieties mixed together they don't
really make blends they just excited
with what shows up at the door I was
really surprised to see just like them
all thrown together like that yeah I can
see yeah they're not the prettiest
apples but they make great great great
tasting cider traditionally they were
made in these giant oak Baptists is
Roberto like the owner of a large cidery
yeah I can so like that's what they're
traditionally made I made in nowaday is
there it's more like white wine
production a lot of the facilities look
similar to a lot of wineries I've been
to yeah I got to help empty how to press
and some smaller like incidentally yeah
this is like you know I couldn't a
smaller side area I was able to check
out there's all the funny and so they
really diversified they're trying to
like export egg and grow and grow the
markets they're trying to diversify what
they're producing so this is your
traditional Australian cider they're
also trying to make bottle conditioned
like fermented ciders that are similar
to a to a champagne selling apple cider
vinegar or this is a still cider which
is like with some juice added back to
make it a little bit sweeter so they're
trying to like to export more and and
diversify what they're doing so it's
interesting to see like how they're
trying to move to move things their bio
state a couple other fun things I was a
port though for a weekend with with
Ignacio there's a lot of fun there I am
at a port house with with Malay his wife
I hiked 100 kilometres along the Camino
de Santiago it's an old pickle an old
pilgrim route I got a
Compostela from the Catholic Church it
took again to heaven free card so I got
that going for me my parents came by I
got to show them around just when to
like to play tour guide there we are in
Sevilla so that was a lot of fun and
then I went away oh and I probably ate
about my bump my own bodyweight in home
owned it is it's his own thing it yeah
you got a yeah yeah you got to try it
it's its own food group it's fantastic
but then in the final weeks of Nigeria I
went down to Peru rapidly as when you
know I lived there for a while I went
there for the wedding of my two good
friends Nellie and Killian which was a
lot of fun I got to read at their
wedding which is I get a little nervous
reading in Spanish in front of a couple
hundred people but it worked out fine
there's a lot of fun well I also was
able to check out great production when
I was down there which is really
different than others you can just see
how barren all this is and so they
produce a lot of different varieties up
here this is Octavio he runs like a
pisco production area pisco it's a like
a grappa lauren who so it's a distilled
grape flicker and so he was growing
grapes out here that were in bloom and
he had LeBrock Alliance on the other
side that were already in brace and
basically they control where the because
isn't this like semi tropical
environment where they could roll
everything with irrigation and pruning
they can get three harvests in two years
off of their lebra Ska's but they try
and just do one a year for their like
for their brunette for us to make you
know you know I like to make peace go
out of sow is really bizarre to see what
like how they how they do this the area
produces a lot of kochenia which are the
little scale insects that the dye
industry uses to make red dye I can so
and this is the same area where they
grow cactus they even have to irrigate
cactus here like you can yeah like
there's no water it is dry yeah I can
then say yeah just gonna see like with
us still epic stills that they used to
make pisco are next and they also you
know I can so I'm like two feet taller
than everyone there yeah I was I got
lost I like a bit of an oddity there
weren't too many Gringo's making it that
far out into this area around arequipa
to take a look at pisco production hours
able to see like these are the old
fermenting baths that they use some of
these date back to the 1700s
mostly more from the like the early to
mid-1800s in here but like these are
just what the old old technology that's
still in use use areas to and like to
ferment to ferment in and then these
piece goes this is like this that's what
like an old press looks like and then
this is like these are what like the
clay vessels you know called piece ghost
that were originally used to train
ferment and then transport piece go in
and this is an eco which is the primary
great producing region in Peru which is
its again like a desert that's like
that's right outside of Iike I mean it
has some of the tallest sand dunes in
the world you get barren doesn't even
start to describe it and then you just
have like the slice of green that that
goes through there where they irrigate
everything some of the oldest
agriculture in the Americas comes from
coastal Peru in this area where they
were irrigating like surprisingly they
were irrigating cotton and not a food
crop there you're getting cotton to make
textiles and nets to go fish on like on
the coast with but yeah so like really
really old history of irrigation and
agriculture in this area we're also the
oldest vineyards in South America or in
this area as well but that's where I
finished up my travels from from I'd
written it was able to come home right
before Christmas so I want to say thank
you thank you thank you to the trio
committee for letting me have this
amazing experience being away also gave
me a lot of time to reflect and figure
out what isn't what I do and I think
that I wouldn't have wound up back here
to work on my PhD if it weren't for that
and I'm really excited about what's
coming down the road so so thank you for
that opportunity I learned so much in
addition to that as well this is just
the tip of the iceberg kind of give you
like the highlights of like of what
happened when I was away but if you have
any other questions I'd be more than
happy to
for you Justine ain't here no no that we
space them like they've just given a lot
more space between trees and again in
this it's a dry area but it's not as dry
as other parts I mean so in in epic on
there's this enough water around its
it's so pretty scrubby but they have oak
forests in the area it's not like Toro I
showed you with a three meter by 3
meters facing south as guarantors - so
there is some moisture there and they
just I just like with grapevines where
they space them out they have lower
yields for her area yeah they were
yeah well at the price point of almonds
right now that making money off of it
they're putting more in yeah we'll see
how long that lasts
get weather like these trees will be
into production down the road but yeah
it's working from that it depends on the
denomination of origin but yes I know
that
and in certain areas they do in in
events with a sherry production and call
them you know grapes they really try and
limit back just because there's a
tendency to try and crops up heavy maybe
there and so they have one of the oldest
denomination like that the oldest
domination of origin in Spain is from
Piraeus
and they tankers pull up there yeah so
there is no control in other areas
you're not supposed to produce hybrid
lines or lacrosse goes and any areas and
a couple growing around
rather than for personal consumption
yeah so there's some control but it's
not as regulated as Franks it wasn't the
other big impression that I got yeah
yeah
yeah while a lot of it comes down to
clothes from our selection now a lot of
these are Spanish grapes that they used
that like that were developed in these
areas that get extraordinarily hot they
also try and in the more vegetation
around the fruit zone because it's so
dried they don't have to worry about
disease pressure that you have to worry
about it in other areas by having less
airflow or less light penetration on the
berries to by shaving them more with
leaves you protect them more yeah you'll
have to worry as much about honey about
disease pressure so you can still get
away with it and it gets up to 40 45
degrees but that's not that's not the
entire season they'll have it in July
and in August you know get these big
temperatures but and other times of the
year it'll be okay cool you also have
these big diner no swings in temperature
because you have a cure in such a dry
climate as well so it may only reach
that hot for a couple of hours
any final questions thanks so much this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu